[Music]
in star trek picard season two episode
four we finally learn what the deal is
with picard's accent spot a reference
that's been with trek for more than 50
years and we also learned that gainen
stays strapped no matter what century
she's in
in the fourth episode watcher picard and
girardi leave the confines of the la
serena and head to the picard chateau in
2024. oh dear so chateau picard is
abandoned in this era
nearly a century at this point the
former enterprise captain explains that
at this point in history nearly 400
years in the past the picard vineyard
has been abandoned for generations and
it will be decades before the picard's
return to occupy it once again while
giving jaradi a brief tour picard
finally resolves the debate regarding
his backstory that has raged among
trekkies for more than three decades
according to picard during the second
world war nazi's occupying france used
his family's chateau as a base of
operations his family only survived he
says when they fled into the underground
tunnels from there the family escaped
across the english channel to the united
kingdom this is a long-awaited
explanation as to why jean-luc picard a
frenchman is played by the english actor
patrick stewart with no discernible
french accent it sounds like after
arriving in the united kingdom the
picard's assimilated into english
culture keeping their british accents
even after returning to france more than
a century later
having brought the borg queen aboard the
las serena to help guide them back in
time picard and his crew once again rely
on her for interdimensional knowledge
the board queen claims to know the
location of the watcher a being with
awareness of other timelines which might
be able to help them however to access
the information dratty needs to be
partially assimilated it's a risky
procedure but she convinces picard it's
the only way they get some of the
information they need but much of it is
scrambled in gerardi's head while picard
gives her a tour of his family's french
chateau jarratti begins subconsciously
fixating on the number 15. picard points
out that while in the chateau's library
she moves 15 beads on an abacus selects
the 15th volume of an encyclopedia and
picks up a bottle of pinot noir from
1915. this seems to indicate that
there's some information rattling around
in her subconscious something picard
would recognize because he's seen this
sort of thing before the subconscious
fixation feels like a direct nod to the
events of the next generation episode
cause and effect in that episode the
enterprise is stuck in a repeating loop
of time and data implants a subconscious
message to himself regarding the number
three to help solve the dilemma perhaps
thanks to this experience picard can
recognize the same phenomenon in gerardi
and see the fixation on 15 as a
potentially helpful subconscious message
time travel is at the core of some of
the most classic star trek stories and
provides some of the franchise's most
memorable moments one such instance is
from star trek for the voyage home which
sees kirk and spock aboard a commuter
bus after traveling back in time to san
francisco there a large mohawk sporting
punk is carrying a boombox and blaring
loud music specifically the song i hate
you written and performed by star trek
producer kirk thatcher annoyed by the
crass music and cacophony of disruptive
noise kirk asks the punk to turn it down
only to be met with a middle finger
seeing no other choice spock reaches
forward and gives the man a vulcan neck
pinch knocking him unconscious and
turning off the music in the picard
episode watcher we get a repeat of this
scene but with far different results
while seven and raphi travel on a
similar commuter bus in los angeles
another mohawk punk carries a boombox
playing a slightly altered new version
of the same song i still hate you this
time though when seven angrily asks the
man to turn the music off the punk goes
from angry to ashamed turning off his
boombox before sheepishly apologizing
for causing the pair any trouble i just
like that song
okay i'm sorry
sorry apologies
seeking the watcher picard finally gets
a set of coordinates and beams over
finding himself in a familiar alley he
materializes at 10 forward avenue the
same location as gainan's bar in the
25th century and realizes that gainen
may be the person he's looking for
however it's a much smaller detail
that's sure to draw the eyes of long
time trekkies as a brick wall in the
background holds a well-worn star trek
prop a poster for a boxing match at
madison square garden first appearing in
the classic star trek episode the city
on the edge of forever the poster has
since become an iconic easter egg across
the franchise making reappearances in
other time travel episodes it turned up
in the background of past tense a
two-part story on deep space nine when
o'brien and kira travel back to the 20th
century looking for cisco dax and bashir
the poster was seen again just barely in
the star trek enterprise episode
stormfront when history is altered and
captain archer finds himself in nazi
occupied new york city in 1944. whether
it was left up on the wall for decades
or is some sort of 21st century rematch
we still have to wonder why they're
advertising a boxing match occurring at
madison square garden in downtown los
angeles
entering the bar picard discovers a much
younger guidance now played by actress
ego agaieri with a much different
attitude far more cynical this guy named
in 2024 has had enough of the human race
and is about to close her bar and depart
planet earth she also doesn't recognize
picard and that makes sense after cue
altered history there was no longer a
starship enterprise to travel back in
time to 1893 and allow picard and
company to first meet gainan in the tng
episode timezero it's possible that her
new less hopeful attitude is a result of
never having met picard and getting a
peek into humanity's and her own future
if you're here to drink you're late
you're here to loot you're early when
she meets picard in watcher gainan is
more than just cynical she's distrusting
and suspicious she makes it known she
won't tolerate a thief by pulling a
shotgun out from under the bar this
should come as no surprise to fans of
the next generation who will remember
that gainan is known for keeping a
powerful firearm at her side in the
episode night terrors when fear grips
the enterprise and a fight breaks out in
the ship's lounge gynon pulls a phaser
rifle from under her bar but in 2024 a
simple pump action shotgun is all she
needs to ward off thieves brawlers and
malcontents your suspicions madame
gaiden are undoubtedly based upon your
keen observational skills
viewers still reeling from the
surprising sight of a younger gainan and
a new actress playing her may have
missed the next easter egg walking
through the streets of downtown l.a
geinan is headed to donate some items
from her bar which she has decided to
close down before she leaves the planet
she and picard stop at a tent labeled
21st street mission donation center
where they drop off guidance donations
to benefit the less fortunate of course
the 21st street mission is nothing new
in star trek as it was previously seen
in the episode city on the edge of
forever when kirk and spock travel back
to 1930s new york they're aided by edith
keeler who runs the 21st street mission
a homeless shelter that houses feeds and
clothes those in need excuse me miss
where are
we you're in the 21st street mission
at the tail end of the fourth episode
watcher we find q sitting at a table
outdoors reading a copy of a
contemporary newspaper the los angeles
times in this version of 2024 it seems
the world has the same issues as the
real world in 2022 with one headline
noting that brenner fights unionization
the headline is referenced to chris
brenner the wealthy magnate from the
star trek deep space nine time travel
episode past tense there he appeared as
something of a cross between bill gates
and rupert murdoch brenner is the owner
and ceo of a tech conglomerate called
brenner information systems and wields
political influence through the several
network channels he controls while he
presents himself as an elitist he seems
genuinely good-hearted and helps stacks
locate her friends in the sanctuary
district even coming to question the
ethics of his time however the headline
of the paper held by q reveals that
brenner is now anti-union suggesting
that he is more in common with the
corporate ethics of his era than we
previously thought
as q sits at an outdoor dining area
reading the los angeles times a young
woman comes walking out of the nasa
facility where they are preparing for
the upcoming space flight mission to
europa the building is marked
conspicuously as the jackson roykirk
plaza which at first might seem like the
name of a real-life landmark in los
angeles however fans of star trek the
original series will spot the name right
away as a reference to a character
mentioned in the episode the changeling
in that episode captain kirk and the
enterprise encounter a long-lost earth
space probe called nomad that was
launched in 2002 the probe which was
designed by a brilliant 21st century
scientist named jackson roykirk was
piloted by an artificial intelligence
given a mission to seek out new life in
the galaxy unfortunately the probe's
logic systems identified the aliens it
encountered as imperfect and turned
against them this is the creator of
nomad
perhaps the most brilliant though
erratic scientist of his time
it seems that in the fictional 2024
scene on picard roykirk is still
remembered as one of the space agency's
leading minds whether he is still alive
and working for them in his later years
or the plaza was named as a memorial to
him after his death remains unknown
speaking of that last scene it's not
just any book the woman is leafing
through it's a book titled the palette
sun by author tracy tormey a sharp eye
will note that the book cover is adorned
with the banner a dixon hill mystery
dixon hill was the name of the fictional
detective in star trek and star of
several novels and later holodeck
programs preferred by jean-luc picard
first mentioned in the next generation
dixon hill has been referenced over the
years in episodes of enterprise and
voyager as well i think
that your marvelous mind is trying to
tell us something
look at you dixon hill
the book's fictional author tracy tormey
is named after the real life writer of
the next generation episode that the
detective series first appeared in the
big goodbye ready for san francisco mr
whalen
more than ready sir
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]